und im studio begrüße ich jetzt hans
dieter heumann den sicherheitsexperten
herzlich willkommen bei phoenix hollmann
fangen wir erstmal mit dieser meldung an
bezüglich der moskwa offensichtlich ist
diese schiff schwer beschädigt worden
was würde dieser militärische erfolg
denn offenbar auch russland jetzt
bestätigt hat also dass das schiff
angegriffen wurde von den ukrainern was
würde dieser erfolg für die ukraine
bedeuten ihr lieblings christian
raketenkreuzer dh von wiesenkräuter ist
natürlich die größte die schwerste
kategorie bei der marine und
raketenkreuzer bedeutet dass von diesem
schiff aus die raketen auf die
küstenstädte der küste des schwarzmeer
aber auch von gorzów mehr geschossen
werden
was natürlich die hinweis auf die
notwendigkeit von anti schiffs raketen
die schon ganz früh auf den listen der
ukrainischen regierung auch dänen die
deutschland übergeben wurden stand
bisher haben hauptsächlich ich glaube
ich die briten solche anti schiffs
raketen geliefert nun befürchten die
ukraine ja eine sozusagen eine offene
feldschlacht im südosten der präsident
teilt misst mit viel russische verbände
machen sich dorthin auf den weg was ist
da zu erwarten und welche waffen würden
den ukrainern in dieser situation denn
helfen ja das ist eine zweite phase des
krieges und sie ist eine ganz andere
wahrscheinlich als die erste der
versuchte einnahme von kiew es ist eine
wie sie sagen selbst eine offene
feldschlacht schon deswegen weil wir
befinden uns hier auch der auf der
steppe so im song pass offenes gebiet
anders als in kiew
die offensive wird eine große seien sie
aber angekündigt die frage ist folgende
im sommers stehen an der
demarkationslinie also an der grenze der
separatisten überblicken innerhalb aber
der oberste der regierungsbezirke lorenz
und thomas stehen
50.000 circa 50.000 ukrainische truppen
sehr gut ausgebildete die auch in den
letzten jahren dort die
verteidigungsstellung ausgebaut haben
die sehr wirksam sein können und die
frage ist ob jetzt russische truppen
versuchen vom norden also südlich von
hartz iv über ist
jugoslawiens vielleicht oder das theater
don jetzt und von süden
die ukrainischen truppen einzukesseln an
dieser die reformations fliegende steht
und normalerweise sagt man beim militär
die angreifer brauchen hier eine
dreifache übermacht die sehe ich im
augenblick auf russischer seite nicht
okay wie soldaten her jetzt gibt es
nachrichten aus washington dass die
amerikaner 18 haubitzen also artillerie
hubschrauber und gepanzerte fahrzeuge
liefern werden man hat den etat an
waffenlieferungen noch einmal um 800
millionen dollar aufgestockt insgesamt
3,2 milliarden dollar das ist ja eine
große summe mit mit dieser summe wird
die ukraine unterstützt will sagen die
amerikaner machen gar kein hehl daraus
aus dem was sie liefern in berlin wird
ein großes geheimnis daraus gemacht
werden schwere waffen geliefert oder
nicht haben sie eine erklärung dafür
warum kannst dass scholz ein derartiges
geheimnis daraus macht also ich finde
das völlig unangemessen der situation
die lage ist wirklich ernst wir haben
wahrscheinlich
wenn mario pohl verständlich eingenommen
wird dann den beginn dieser großen
offensive im donbass die ukraine kämpft
um ihre existenz sie braucht jetzt
schwere waffen und das erkennen ja auch
immer mehr in den koalitionsparteien
wir haben ja michael roth vor hingehört
wieder alle drei ausschussvorsitzende
außen europa und verteidigung die drei
regierungsparteien
sind dafür also der kanzler hat meiner
ansicht nach auch hier ein
führungsproblem
es sprechen einige vor und seine
entscheidung ist nicht getroffen
übrigens ein führungsproblem nach innen
und auch nach außen ich bin der
auffassung dass das bisherige verhalten
der bundesregierung
aus den politischen schaden angerichtet
hat ja in eine ähnliche richtung geht
ein o-ton von anton hofreiter den wir
gleich sehen und hören werden jetzt sagt
die bundesregierung ja also unsere
waffen zu liefern beispielsweise marder
panzer oder leopard 1 die ja
offensichtlich zur verfügung ständen
nachdem sie restauriert worden sind
würden den ukrainern in der jetzigen
situation nicht weiterhelfen weil die ja
nicht so schnell einsetzbar werden dann
müssen wir die leute geschult werden
daran usw ist es ein argument aus ihrer
sicht was jedoch ein paar die
waffenlieferung der anderen staaten
schon von der summe her ist litauen er
hat bisher mehr geld
ausgegeben für waffen liefern die
ukraine als die bundesregierung die
slowakei
hat liefert mit 29 kampfflugzeuge
wirklich schwere waffen die tschechen
liefern
sowjetische panzer aus früherer zeit
also wir müssen uns nur die und groß die
briten sind sie vielleicht das beste
beispiel wir haben uns die angucken kann
können wir die argumente der
bundesregierung nicht verstehen und wird
das eine linie ändern müssen in den
nächsten tagen ich glaube ich schon das
wird man sehen herr räumen vielen dank
für diesen analysen danke dass sie heute
bei uns im studio waren also der
angesprochene anton